[Music]
what was it like being on the set of
something like
wolf of wall street and watching a
leonardo dicaprio
give like go to an 11 in basically every
single scene
he's in and just in terms of how he
carried himself on a set like that
somebody this just came up recently and
i was like i am i think he's the
most impressive uh actor i've
ever worked with in terms of like a i
that's not true i've worked with
great actors leonardo dicaprio is a
movie star right so there's no
expectation
we we have very low expectations for how
a movie star
is going to behave uh prepare
he he's a he's an actor he's a real like
he he comes incredibly prepared he
knows everyone's name he's kind he's
professional
um and uh it really blew me away
because i hadn't um i i don't know you
you wash these people with the same
brush
right because it's like famous movie
stars
um or he's dating so and so that the
nonsense that we
we sort of put out about people he he's
really spectacular and
and everyone on that set i mean i
remember standing next to
like can i tell these stories um
i remember standing next to john favreau
who was there for a couple days
and he was just standing next to me and
he was like isn't this amazing
like he was just as in awe as i was
he was just so like excited to be there
and he was like you have no idea how
like how marty scorsese's movies
like what they've meant to me this is
amazing that i'm here
and i was like that's great i want i
want to always feel like that
i feel like that probably reflects why
john favreau's such a good director and
producer too because i i think you could
feel that love of cinema and the stories
that he's creating kind of
radiating off the screen of his uh films
and shows and
i love that quality about them yeah
on that set you are right smack in the
middle
of a lot of uh significant set pieces
with wild behavior
of the bunch what was i guess i guess
the craziest
um i can tell a story about a what a
scene that i'm not
in actually
um the craziest for me was the animals
like when the animals showed up and you
realize they're getting paid more than
you are it's a little
insane but um for me
for the craziest story i heard and i
won't say who the actor is but there's a
certain scene
where um they're they're
in an orgy and um they had hired
actors and non-actors um
wanting people to be comfortable with
their bodies because there's a lot of
nudity
and there was some confusion about
what was real and what was not and this
actor had to say
to his scene partner um
please stop licking my balls it's fake
you're gonna probably have to cut that